über die Situation in der Ukraine kann
ich jetzt sprechen mit dem ehemaligen
Nato-General Egon Rams guten Tag Herr
Rams
ja wie bewerten Sie diesen Schritt den
Vladimir Putin gestern gegangen ist hat
das Kriegsrecht verhängt ist das ein
Beweis für militärische Schwierigkeiten
Moskau
also ich würde jetzt im Augenblick noch
nicht von Beweis reden aber es ist eine
völlig veränderte Situation gegenüber
all dem was wir in den letzten acht
Monaten in der Ukraine erlebt haben
es schafft eine neue aus seiner Sicht
eine neue Rechtslage wobei wir immer im
Auge behalten müssen dass die
Annektierung dieser Gebiete und jetzt
auch die Ausrufung des kriegsrechtes
letztendlich neben dem Völkerrecht nicht
vereinbar ist er schafft eine Situation
wo die russische Streitkräfte gegenüber
der Zivilbevölkerung ich sage das mal
Macht ausüben können und auf diese Art
und Weise und auf diese Art und Weise
beispielsweise Deportationen durchführen
können die Leute auch mit Gewalt
rüberbringen können über den lepburn
nach Süden und von daher hat die haben
die russische Streitkräfte jetzt
wesentlich mehr Macht als sie vorher
gehabt haben aber noch mal das ist alles
rechtswidrig sie haben die Situation
schon angesprochen die wir vor allen
Dingen jetzt in der Stadt herson
vorfinden dass dort eben die
Zivilbevölkerung
evakuiert wird wie lange also hat ja
eine
europäisch wichtige Bedeutung es liegt
zwischen der von Russland anitierten
Krim und zwischen Nikolaev und auch
Odessa ist nicht weit im Osten was
glauben sie kann Russland herrson halten
da werden wird er jetzt eine große
Offensive seitens der Ukraine erwartet
also wir können feststellen dass in den
letzten Tagen die Ukraine über diesen
Raum relativ wenig geredet hat das
könnte ein Anzeichen dafür sein ähnlich
wie vor einigen Wochen im Raum chakif
dass die Ukraine tatsächlich hier eine
entsprechende Offensive vorbereitet und
versuchen wird kerson zu nehmen die
Ukraine muss an strategisches Interesse
daran haben das gesamte Nordufer des die
nepro in diesem Bereich in die eigene
Hände zu bekommen und auf diese Art und
Weise eine stärkere Trennlinie zu den
russischen Kräften zu ziehen und
praktisch dann von da an die
Operationsführung weil möglicherweise
dann auch weiter nach Süden entsprechend
weiter vorbereiten zu können dann lassen
Sie uns noch mal darauf schauen was wir
in den letzten Tagen erlebt haben da hat
Russland Schah halt Drohnen eingesetzt
sogenannte kamikazedonen iranischer
Bauart und hat damit vor allen Dingen
die Energieinfrastruktur getroffen und
auch die Zivilbevölkerung 30 Prozent der
Energieinfrastruktur der Ukraine ist
bereits zerstört die Menschen müssen
jetzt stundenweise ohne Strom auskommen
der ukrainische Präsident selenski hat
den Einsatz von Drohnen als bezeichnet
als Zeichen dafür dass das Putin quasi
ich sage jetzt mal salopp blank da steht
wir sehen Sie das ist das pura Terror
oder wird damit tatsächlich irgendwie
militärisch irgendwas gewonnen
also militärische Gewinne sind damit
bisher nicht erzielt worden und werden
auch mit dem weiteren Einsatz dieses
drogentyps nicht erzielt werden der
richtet seine Angriffe gegen die zivile
und wichtige Infrastruktur dazu gehört
mit die Energie und die Stromversorgung
und der richtet sie auch gleichzeitig
mit gegen die Zivilbevölkerung das heißt
er setzt im Prinzip das fort was den
anderen Teilen auch oben im Norden bei
chaki vorher schon gemacht hat der
terrorisiert die Zivilbevölkerung er
macht dieses mit Hilfe dieser Drohnen
auch in großen Teilen der Ukraine und
das wird die zielvölkerung verunsichern
und sie muss die Zivilbevölkerung muss
die Soldaten weiter entsprechend
unterstützen das muss sein einfach damit
die Moral der Soldaten der
amerikanischen Soldaten auch
entsprechend hält das heißt er macht
einen terrorkrieg in dieser Richtung der
sich sowohl gegen wichtige Infrastruktur
als auch gegen die zielbevölkerung
richtet
der Einsatz von Drohnen hat natürlich
auch eine psychologische Komponente dass
man quasi immer irgendwie verletzbar ist
auch aus der Luft jetzt zeigt sich dass
es offenbar Lücken gibt im ukrainischen
Luft System die Nato hat ein weiterer
hat weitere Luftabwehrsysteme zugesagt
aber die Ukraine bittet Israel um irand
um deren Luftabwehrsystem Israel ist da
zögerlich will ein älteres System
liefern wie könnte denn der Westen jetzt
helfen
also der Westen kann so helfen indem er
weitere Flugabwehrsysteme den Ukrainer
zur Verfügung stellt denn das was wir
bisher geliefert haben sei es von der
deutschen Seite her sei es von anderer
Unterstützung her ist relativ wenig und
wenn wir eine flächendeckende
Luftverteidigung mit der Ukraine
aufbauen wollten so würde ich sagen dass
es im Augenblick erstmal nicht möglich
da müssten viele Systeme wie
beispielsweise das Iris t müssten erst
noch entsprechend in großen Stückzahlen
produziert werden von daher ist das ein
sehr schwieriges Unterfangen diese
Drohnen diese kamikazedonen tragen zum
Terror gegenüber der Zivilbevölkerung
bei und Sie können möglicherweise auch
auf die Zivilbevölkerung die ja überall
durch diese Drohnen erreichbar ist
demoralisiert werden jetzt hat Kiew in
den letzten Tagen auch noch
Raketenangriffe aus Belarus vermehrt
gemeldet wie hoch schätzen Sie denn die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ein dass Belarus doch
noch Kriegspartei wird
was ist eine sehr schwierige Frage der
Präsident Lukaschenko hat sich ja für
Weißrussland bisher aus diesen
Kriegsgeschehen rausgehalten wir hatten
zu Beginn oder kurz vor Beginn des
Krieges eine gemeinsame russische
belarussische Übung auf belarussischem
Territorium aber es haben bisher keine
Soldaten von Weißrussland die Grenze
nach Süden Richtung Ukraine
überschritten von daher hat er sich
einigermaßen neutral gehalten ich glaube
auch nicht dass er einen Weg gehen wird
wo er die Russen in diesem Bereich
unmittelbar unterstützen wird der hat
von Anfang an das Krieges auch
Flughäfen in Weißrussland zur Verfügung
gestellt für die russische Luftwaffe
aber weißrussische Soldaten sind bisher
nach in die Ukraine hinein nicht
einmarschiert und haben auch dort nicht
aktiv in den Kämpfen teilgenommen von
daher ist es eine spezielle Situation ob
er sich dazu überreden lässt oder
zwingen lässt von Putin sich jetzt auch
aktiv am Krieg in dieser Form zu
beteiligen das muss abgewartet werden
ich meine es nicht
mehr viel Zeit aber eine wichtige Frage
dennoch an sie wie blicken sie denn auf
den weiteren Verlauf dieses Krieges
zeitlich und mit welchen erfolgen für
welche Kriegspartei
also russland hat offensichtlich
Probleme mit Blick auf Soldaten und
Material daher auch diese teilmobil
machen die durchgeführt worden ist das
sieht für die ukrainische Seite doppelt
oder wesentlich besser aus weil sowohl
die Zivilbevölkerung als auch die
Soldaten mit einer hohen Moral diese
Verteidigung weiter fortführen wollen es
hängt letztendlich im Ergebnis von uns
ab vom Westen ab welche Waffensysteme
wir der Ukraine liefern damit Sie diesen
Verteidigungskrieg weiter aufrecht
erhalten und erfolgreich gestalten kann
vielen Dank für das Gespräch Egon Ranz
ich danke Ihnen auch wieder